[Applause]  four-twenty is cheers we kept it just  the way you left it it's over  really the classifieds have the perfect  job for you we've been looking over your  resume and we're looking for someone  with a bit more experience here's your  desk the one with the view drinks for  everyone yeah see ya dude can you  believe they're just throwing this away  what do you mean you don't want to be in  a committed relationship are you oh I've  got two tickets to paradise uh okay this  is really important  [Music]  [Applause]  buddy looking big feeling that burn bro  [Music]  the team was really excited to have you  we're working when I go to market  that's your first date joke come on  [Music]  you